I'm writing every Devil's fruit in one
piece to figure out which is the best
one this is the Ino inonomi model wolf
which turns its user into a wolf it was
eaten by Jabra a member of the world
government Secret Agency cp9 similar to
any other animal devil fruit it allows
you to transform into a full wolf or a
wolf human hybrid and you'll also get
the usual enhanced power and speed so a
howling 15 out of 25 points for strength
for defense all animal fruits get super
upgraded recovery and durability so
another 15 points here as for special
abilities a wolf is a predator and gets
a natural boost in aggression and power
so sink your teeth into five more points
for that and while this would probably
won't make you anyone's favorite pet it
is incredibly useful to survive out in
the wild and you even get this nice warm
fluffy coat so another 10 points here
and since there are no real weaknesses
or drawbacks the wolf would earns a
fantastic 45 points leaving it at number
four and just off the podium forget
[Music]